[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream number 37
q a section with dr heather heing
all right here we go here we go there we
go we're going to start with a couple of
comments
from the super chat in episode 36 and
one
question from last time and then move
right into the questions from the last
hour
comment number one from august 4th i am
right-leaning libertarian you are
left-leaning and we need to come
together against this mess of a state
yes yes we do thank you for that the
this
being crucial this mess of a state
doesn't have to be and we don't have to
agree on what the resolution
what state should or should not exist in
order to recognize
that um our current form of governance
has become
parasitic malignant and must be
addressed
nothing riding on it about the game
that's right
second comment from last time i tried
talking sense against anti-reason in my
school
i failed post-modernism reigns in urban
public ed
sorry internet mom dad and fellow
americans
i think we can still make headway i
think we have to turn it around
but uh it's getting harder with every
passing day yeah
um there's something to be said for uh
you have had the same experience
that almost everyone has had and so in
some sense
you are going to discover uh kindred
spirits by virtue of
having similar scars sorry it happened
but
that's simply the nature of the beast at
this point
yep okay uh
final question from episode 36
what is the importance of genitals
hormones chromosomes
gonads and secondary sex characteristics
when describing gender
i've heard them called outdated so it's
a tiny question
yeah just a little question uh you want
to go on your
your usual riff here a little my little
tirade um
yeah so sex sex is basically binary
um the gametes that we produce um
uh being the thing that is most
fundamental to what sex is
if you produce or have produced or might
produce or will produce at some point in
your development
in your life history small mobile
gametes that have been stripped of most
of the cytoplasm
plasm you are male and those gametes are
called sperm if you're a plant they're
called pollen
if you produce have produced might
produce will produce etc at some point
in your life history gametes that are
large and
sessile don't move filled with cytoplasm
then you are female and those gametes
are called eggs
from that truth and we have in our
lineage 500 uninterrupted
million years of sexual reproduction
uh wherein you can point to that's male
that's female you find a new species
you figure out what gametes they produce
and you know who's male who's female
even if the
organism looks unlike anything else that
you have ever seen they will have
large immobile gametes or small mobile
gametes and that is how you know
gender is the behavioral expression
of sex chromosomes in the case of
mammals and birds different evolution
um can delineate which sex you're going
to become
genitals are primary sexual
characteristics
that are used to deliver those gametes
hormones are physiological mechanisms by
which
sex is displayed
and manifest in the body secondary sex
characteristics
um like facial hair and persistent and
large breasts
in women are manifestations
of the chromosomes of the
of the hormones and all of it stems from
originally the binary of sex so if
secondary sex chromosomes and
or rather secondary sex characteristics
and genitals
are produced by sex why is it that as
soon as we get to behavior we decide
that these are not correlated this is
totally cultural it has nothing to do
with evolution
um this is a religious standpoint so no
it's not outdated
uh what is outdated is the frankly
religious approach that suggests that
the behavioral manifestation of sex
some of which are in fact
um kind of old school and we can get rid
of some of the
old-style gender norms we don't need any
more
but gender is the behavioral expression
of sex all these other things are other
expressions of sex
sex is binary gender isn't but it's
still strongly bimodal
all right so if i can just add a couple
things please um
one 500 million good years of sex
that's that's not a bad run they were
also good yeah
all right i don't know i wasn't there
for all of them yeah true
the thing that i sometimes hear you say
is that
um the gamete issue
is wildly correlated with the other
downstream things there's of course
ambiguous genitals and things but in
general the
gametes which are binary are predictive
of the chromosomes that you will find in
the cells they are predictive of the
secondary sexual characteristics that
you will find
and they are predictive of the behavior
not all the time
but almost all the time they are
predictive of it and
the meaning of this which we rarely get
to
is that gender being the software of sex
that software
fits the difference in gametes which
predicts a difference in reproductive
strategy from which
all of the distinctions between males
and females that we find in culture
after culture
derive so cross culture across time over
and over and over again
the thing that you're being misled about
is that the software
is arbitrary because it's software it
could be anything you could swap out
male characteristics for females
no you can't the reason you can't is
because the strategy derives
from the biological underpinnings
that trace all the way back to this
difference in gamete size
which is universal and sexual creatures
yeah it emerges in part from a sort of
cultural blank slatism
which emerges itself in part at least in
academic circles from
cultural anthropology's missteps in the
middle of the last century
um in which it was uh it was argued
successfully apparently such that the
entire field is mostly captured now
uh that culture is is arbitrary and
uh whatever one culture is doing could
just as easily have been a whole other
suite of things and
no it's not true you know culture fits
the environment in which the people who
are
who have created that culture live and
similarly
uh the behavior of sex fits the sex
that uh the environment in which the
different sexes have
experienced life and you know as the
environment changes and obviously it is
changing very rapidly now
gender norms will change as well and
they will become more fluid and we can
have
we can have a much less uh old-school
old-fashioned archaic regressive
understanding
of what women are supposed to be doing
and what men are supposed to be doing
but we can't imagine that it was
arbitrary from the beginning
that it had no uh that it had no reason
for being
or that it is going to be possible to
get rid of all of the things
uh that are effectively behavioral
downstream effects of sex
so um the way to remember this
is that even if you look at plants the
parts that
are male are much more enthusiastic for
example about
having sex with other plants
than the female parts right that's they
don't do a life history first
they just go and have sex right and the
thing is it's for the same reason that
you find this
in animals which is that the females the
large gamete
is the beginning of this strategy in
which females are predisposed to greater
investment in offspring which causes
choosiness to pay back
so if you can find that in a plant that
literally doesn't think about anything
it's incapable
of being culturally oppressed or
anything else now you're going to be
pissed off the plant enthusiasts
and the maybe even the plants that are
conscious plant enthusiasts yes
um but anyway the fact is this is a very
ancient pattern and it's there for
reasons that aren't that hard to
understand
it didn't get invented in humans it
wasn't invented by a patriarchy
doesn't mean it's not time to introduce
some changes we can renegotiate the deal
between the sexes but let's not
pretend it doesn't arise out of
something comprehensible
and and certainly aspects of this have
been taken advantage of
uh by by regimes and by individuals
throughout history 100
just just like with with race you know
we when we say this we are not claiming
uh that you know that sexism isn't real
hasn't been real and but
but but and i don't know that i've we've
said this anywhere else just like
historical racism has been much worse in
the us
in the past than it is now historical
sexism has been much worse in the past
than it is now
and so these hyperbolic
and frankly just flat-out wrong claims
that sexism is an all-time high and
racism is an all-time high
you we just know this isn't true and
therefore you can start to suspect
almost anything that
else that comes out of such people's
mouths when they make those claims
absolutely yeah
okay on to the first question from um
from today's
live stream from
from tommy unique name would you
consider using score voting instead of
ranked choice voting
i recommend podcast 2012 106
october 6th interview with nobel
laureate dr kenneth arrow
by the center for election science where
dr arrow says that
score voting is probably the best in
practice i didn't recognize i don't
recognize score voting as a term but
um obviously arrow is a is a person who
is familiar to both of us
yes he is actually the person on this
because he
proved uh arrow's impossibility theorem
was that there was no mechanism
uh no voting system that you could
institute that would get
a vote inherently to represent the
actual will of the people now
the system we have is particularly bad
and i take it
that um ken arrow's indication
of score voting uh means that although
he has proven that it can't possibly
represent it
perfectly that it is much closer to
representing it so presumably there is a
scale
of the degree to which a voting system
represents the
will of the people that is to say um
the collective output of not only
the order of preferences but the degree
of preferences that weights these things
properly
so anyway i'd be certainly interested in
looking into it there is a question
we have a couple of constraints here one
is
you know how do we get a system that is
superior to
first past the post so rank choice
voting is one possibility
score voting is apparently another and
there's a question about the practical
details of getting this into some system
that actually works
which is something that we face inside
unity 2020 and i would say
ranked choice voting is good enough
maybe score voting is better
hopefully score voting is both better
and easier to implement and
uh yeah i'd be happy to look into it
yeah
good tip are you familiar with gregory
bateson's correlation between the basic
unit of survival
parentheses flexible organism in its
environment and the basic unit of mind
parentheses news of a different flowing
in a circuit
if not google forms substances a
difference his 1972 paper
this sounds vaguely familiar but i don't
i can't i couldn't pinpoint it i'm i'm
i have a vague recollection of a
lunchtime discussion
in the insect division at the umc
but i don't remember it well enough to
even comment on it yeah but i will uh
i'll highlight this
um to remind us to take a look hopefully
okay thank you for that unity 2020
flagship policy suggestion
rank ordered voting i should have put
this right next to the other one it
eliminates the reality of spoiler
candidates no spoiler candidates means
people get to give the non-evil choice a
try and put their lesser of evil's
choice as a fallback
yep so this is what this is what the
plan is maybe score voting would be
better
yep and long term but but the but the
default
the default plan is rank choice which is
the same as rank order
well i don't want to promise anything
because the implementation layer
is not my purview and the people who are
doing it are you know
stretched pretty thin but yes our
objective is to solve this problem
as well as we can yeah and am i right so
i just i'm
i'm out of my depth here ranked choice
and ranked ordered voting is going to be
the same thing
i certainly think so yeah yeah okay
this question is four questions and
they're big ones
are more males born after wars do
attractive parents have more girls
if either what's the mechanism does
anybody know
um so these are those are actually two
very different
questions although they're both related
to well the first one is specifically
related to the question of sex ratios
yep
and uh the second one is
a little bit the one about attractive
parents having more girls is a little
bit
uh related to sex ratios but more
um more to the question of sexual
selection and
how as parents can you maximize um
your genes going forward [ __ ] you know
as we've said over and over and over
again it's an uninteresting goal and in
humans
um this is sort of the least of what
parents do um but it obviously still is
part of what parents do
is uh leaving copies of themselves the
next generation
hear that zach all right yeah he's he's
on it um
so are more males born after wars so
you can do a number of things here first
of all just to make it clear why you
would expect it
is that wars tend to eliminate men they
don't just eliminate men
right wartime is bad for all sorts of
things for all sorts of reasons but
because men fight wars and i believe
that is a cultural universal
yes um that men do the actual fighting
they are killed
at greater rates which would leave you
to expect that the production of men
well there's two ways to think about it
you could think about it at a lineage
level
where there is a need for men and you
could think of it at
the individual level that is to say that
from the point of view of a parent
physiologically choosing whether to
produce a male or a female
females are liable to be in surplus
males are liable to be
scarce and therefore a male that you had
after war might be disproportionately
successful
both of which can be understood from a
sex racial perspective which is to say
um it's fisher right who does sex ratio
stuff um so r.a fisher
the father of minor statistics and one
of the best evolutionary biologists of
the 20th century
one of his contributions was
understanding
that um not even all else being equal
but in almost every circumstance in
almost every circumstance there are
exceptions
uh we expect the sex ratio at the
average age of first reproduction
uh to uh be one to one in populations
um and you know his logic is a sort of
population level logic
uh which says basically if you have an
abundance of one sex
parents who can influence uh the sex
ratio of their own offspring
will end up having better luck in
producing grand offspring
if they produce the sex that is
currently underrepresented in the
population
so i would point out that there's a very
interesting
outgrowth of this discussion i wrote an
essay many years ago
on the hazard of the one child policy in
china that it was going to make china
warlike and that maybe that was even its
purpose because
it produced surplus males who were going
to not be successful in finding mates
and who would constitute the substance
from which an army would naturally be
constructed
and it violates the one child policy
violates the logic of fisher which is to
say
you would expect in a country with a
surplus of males that females would be
prized as offspring which is the
opposite of what we see well it's just
it's not the one child policy
itself does not either predict this nor
violate
uh what fisher found and revealed about
sex ratios it is the
cultural valuing of boy children over
girl children overlaid on a one child
policy that then produces too many boys
such that you have um not enough not
enough girls and therefore and they're
after not enough women
right so the question in this case
is first of all uh is there conflict
between the population level analysis
and the individual level analysis
in the aftermath of war and which one
should dominate because after all
at least our argument is that it is
lineages that fight wars
typically and that that means that they
are serving a lineage level purpose
well i don't know that there is a
conflict though you know i mean i guess
it depends on the war
wow right it depends on the context you
know if if an area has been so
devastated
that uh most of the men have been killed
and uh
and the women have been either enslaved
and removed or
raped and inseminated um you don't
necessarily well if they've been
enslaved and removed then you don't
necessarily have a sex ratio difference
right um but if uh if
if the women are still there and even if
they now have
within them the children of the of their
their
captors their warlords um you have
uh a a likely move both at the
individual level and the population
level
uh to produce more males yes
potentially there's also another
possibility here
which is that you would see polygeny
break out in the aftermath of wars which
actually i've
predicted would be likely because it
doesn't make sense to sideline
um women reproductively just because
there aren't
you know an equal number of men so in
other words one man can fertilize many
women
in the absence of men as a result of war
you might imagine
um that all women who were capable of
producing offspring would end up
with offspring which i have argued is a
basis for
um lesbian coupling that lesbian
coupling a lesbian couple is perfectly
capable of raising offspring
and gametes aren't that hard to get so
not if you're a woman
not if you're a woman um so in any case
there's a deep
question here but the the one i the
piece i want to point out
is that warfare is frequently going to
happen at least by our model
when um there when there is a deficit of
resources in other words austerity
causes populations to go to war so in
one sense if
you were going to do this analysis and
maybe that the analysis has been done
and maybe that peter turton knows the
answer to this question for one thing
but yeah we don't we don't know we're
talking from an evil
we're trying to make the evolutionary
predictions but we don't actually know
the answer
right yeah but it may be that the answer
is different depending upon whether you
want or lost
right i would imagine that that actually
has some important implications
100 and i i guess i was speaking from
the assumption that we're talking about
the losers
right yeah um but the other thing is if
austerity is generating this
and we have made arguments in other
places for mechanisms to prevent
austerity from causing conflict from
causing violence but in the case that
such mechanisms don't exist or haven't
worked and you have violence in some
sense what it may be doing is backing
the population away from carrying
capacity
which if you do the individual level
analysis
you would expect to have very little
implication because an individual
just because the population may be
better off backing away from
carrying capacity the individual still
has an evolutionary interest
in creating as many copies as they can
in the next generation
on the other hand if we start thinking
in lineage level terms which i would
argue we always should
that at a lineage level it's a very
different analysis because the long-term
well-being of a lineage may indeed
allow for some kind of restraint with
respect to immediate
moving the immediate move back to
carrying capacity well but it's also
true
we have argued i'm not sure that we've
argued publicly yet but you know it's in
it's in our book that
uh that monogamy actually is a way of
filling a landscape more quickly and so
um yes you of course if you if you're
below carrying capacity you expect birth
rate to go up to sort of an obvious
prediction
but you also expect a move further away
from polygamy towards monogamy
as there are more resources available
and more landscape to move into
so i'm alluding to that what i'm getting
at
is that if you have an oscillation at
the at carrying capacity and warfare
results from
some boost in population above normal
carrying capacity that then results in
violence and the violence is a
bloodletting that removes some people
from the population
the evolutionary drive
to go into a population increase mode
that would be facilitated by monogamy
which brings all
potential parents into child rearing
that that might not be incentivized
right so anyway let's just say this is a
complex question sure
um it may be that the pattern you
hypothesize
is there in a general sense it may be
that it's there for
uh winners and not losers or vice versa
um
or it may be that it's absent for other
reasons that
dominate the question that we don't know
but it's certainly worth looking into
yeah now as to the maybe we've spent as
much time as we should on this one but
uh do attractive parents have more girls
uh and
i guess i first read that more broadly
not as attractive but sort of you know
higher quality whatever that means which
would be a direct allusion to the
traverse willard hypothesis
which was published in mid-70s probably
which suggests that because put humans
aside for the moment
because the variability in reproductive
success is so much greater for males
than it is for females that
is um that females no matter
how many matings they get no matter what
the social system is tend to have
you know roughly two surviving offspring
that make it into the next generation
that then go on to reproduce themselves
that is they exactly replace themselves
in a in a stable population situation
whereas males
have a highly variable number of
offspring
and how many they have varies greatly by
the number of reproductive opportunities
that they find for themselves or make
for themselves
so the prediction of the trevor's
wheeler hypothesis is that
the higher the quality offspring you can
produce the more likely you
are to produce males because because
males have such a greater variability in
reproductive success
you want to make sure that your highest
quality offspring are more likely to be
males with a higher variability with a
higher chance of getting
more offspring themselves this is a
purely genetic argument
and obviously with humans where we tend
towards monogamy
and where female beauty in particular is
a
a big predictor of basically wealth
acquisition and also reproductive
success
this may this may at least um mitigate
the effects of trevor's willard or even
flip it on its head
wait wait wait i was with you until that
last okay well i didn't say it will i
said it
it may no no i i thought where you were
headed
um is that uh all else being equal
a very important phrase here all else
being equal
prettier women should tend to have male
offspring
because of the downstream consequences
of beauty
in mating and dating so not only of male
beauty
no i thought we were talking about
female beauty right well but so you just
said
women beautiful women should be more
likely to have male offspring
but if it's because of the role of
female beauty in mating and dating why
wouldn't
why wouldn't you expect a flip of
trevor's willard because
uh beautiful women would be more likely
therefore to
uh to themselves again attract more
high quality mates yeah higher quality
mates they would they would they would
tend to marry
up and therefore the
chances that a male offspring that they
produce would be successful would be
higher than if we take their
beauty out of the equation and we figure
out where they would have made it in the
hierarchy
based on other characteristics so if a
woman can marry
up it should increase the chances of her
producing male offspring
because the offspring will be better
placed to
reproduce themselves and she's less
likely to produce dead ends
so how is that different how how does
the human situation that's just a
classic
trevor's willard argument that doesn't
change in any way like
so the fact of female beauty or not
actually doesn't even belong in that
conversation it's changed the argument
not at all
well right i think this is standard
trooper's bullet i don't know i i have
yet to see why
why the logic would reverse here um it's
just that
beauty plays a certain role in human
mating and dating
and so i mean because there's choice
because because both men and women
choose
yeah it's right um to to a greater
degree than
uh really is found in just about any
other mammals and there are a number of
monogamous species of birds but
um in in a mostly monogamous species as
as we are where you have choice on on
both parts and where
female beauty and specifically
indicators of youth and fertility
are highly prized across culture uh you
might expect a woman with those
characteristics
um to exactly want to replicate them in
her daughters because she will want
daughters who will be similarly chosen
by also highly ranked men because female
beauty doesn't necessarily
convert into the indicators that says
for men right like
you know if success for men is often
about wealth and um
and you know later in life success now i
get your argument
okay but i still think it goes the other
way
precisely because of the thing that sits
at the bottom of the trevor's willard
analysis which is that the variance for
women is lower and therefore
so first of all no matter no matter what
else is true about humans still there's
only so many kids a woman can have in
her lifetime
and the number of kids a man can have in
his lifetime is basically unbounded but
don't try
right but so anyway just just to
complete it
if woman so first of all there is there
are several layers
playing into this discussion one is that
a beautiful woman
is likely genetically well endowed and
has had access to resources
that or her mother did that would result
in you know this is one of the things
that bob trivers has looked deeply into
um is the fluctuating fluctuating
specialization
basically we find symmetry uh pleasing
and so
a woman who is beautiful likely is
genetically well endowed and has also
had a developmental environment that was
hospitable
um which uh you know some of this is
heritable and some of it isn't
right but a beautiful woman is probably
if those characteristics are right
if she's especially symmetrical for one
thing she may also it's not that her
it's not that she is capable of
producing female beauty she is likely
capable of producing
beautiful well put together offspring of
either sex
she is also capable of commanding more
in the mating and dating market
and therefore she you know let's just
say that
male quality physical quality doesn't
even matter
right certain things like a higher
position in society
she can marry somebody who's a higher
position in society which increases the
chances that her offspring
will be able to find mates although
until until very recently until
post-industrial cultures
often higher position in society for
males needed to be vetted with
uh tests of physical prowess early on
yep i still i still think that all these
things point in the same direction
that which is that whatever it is the
female beauty is a proxy for whether it
is
you know mediated through males who are
choosing or whether it is mediated
through nature and her ability to
produce
offspring that are well structured in
both cases the unsettling and
uncomfortable conclusion of trevor's
willard
is if you have some reason to know that
your offspring
are liable to be more capable than
average rather than less capable than
average
then you should tend to produce males
and in a more uncertain context you
should tend to produce
females and that female beauty if it
does anything it tells you
she should be more likely to produce
males because she's more likely to
produce
males that are well positioned and well
structured fair enough
okay we could we could of course go on
for hours as we probably will later yes
we could
off the camera um and i will say and
maybe correct me i
you know i didn't didn't see this
question coming but i think i don't know
that trevor
willard has been investigated with
regard to mechanism in humans or even
investigated
necessarily in humans at all but it has
been looked at in some
species of mammals where the mechanism
actually appears to possibly be
choice of the egg now by the egg of
particular sperm
because mammals have chromosomal sex
determination
um i believe and you know it's possible
i'm just making this up but i but i
think
i think i remember one or two papers
suggesting that basically
the egg knows and obviously none of this
is conscious we're using this
evolutionary shorthand but
the egg can tell x sperm versus y sperm
in a mammal and b z versus w sperm in a
bird no
actually in birds it's going to be
totally different because they've got
this different sexes heterogametic
in birds um but in mammals x-sperm
versus y-sperm the egg can tell and
therefore the egg can make choices based
on the sex of the sperm that is
approaching them
and appears to do so i will try to find
that
find that to make sure that i'm not
making it up for the next time
all right good all right
uh the next question is also
evolutionary which is good because it
would be really hard to switch
completely
after that um is there an evolutionary
advantage to being colorblind
okay it quickly goes non-evolutionary in
your case brett does it help to not fall
for the vote red or vote blue dichotomy
thoughts on oh and now totally different
within the same question thoughts on
doubling the number of reps we've had
435
for almost 100 years could more seats
mean less government capture
i'm probably going to punt on that last
bit i would have to think
about the implications they're not
immediately obvious to me but let's talk
about uh
color blindness yeah first of all you
should know eric and i
have an unusual kind of colorblindness
it's not
red green we have the identical color
blindness which we know because there
are these
marvelous pebble tests that assess which
cones are doing what where you've
probably seen them
it's a round display that has these
different sized dots in it and there's
some
number written in the dots the salient
thing about them is
they're differently colored dots right
but here's the thing that you may not
know because most people see color
approximately the same way is that some
of those tests
have a number in the in them that only a
person with a certain kind of color
blindness can see and eric and i see the
same thing on these charts
just one chart after another so 90 of us
are seeing
seven and ninety percent of the
remaining people see nothing and then
ten percent of the one percent of people
and these numbers are all wrong it's
much less than one percent of the
population that has this particular
color blindness see the number two
instead which no one else can see at all
right yeah um so eric and i could go
through the book separately and we'd
come up with exactly the same
answers and people who see color
normally would all be in an agreement
about what they saw too
so anyway the the reason i raised that
is because red green color blindness
pretty clearly does have an
advantage and marvelously the advantage
seems not to be
an individual level advantage it's a
population level advantage in other
words
it's not like you'd all be better off
being colorblind but you're better off
to be
in a population that has some colorblind
people just like
you are better off being in a population
that has some left-handers
and so there is clearly and i find that
this is true for
me too with my color blindness is that
there
is an increased sensitivity to pattern i
can find things other people can't find
and in fact
we don't know you're talking about
visual pattern but i wonder if it
doesn't
track into other kinds of pattern as
well well i think it has all kinds of
downs analytical patterns
yeah for one thing i think it just
there's probably something to the idea
that if you live in a world of people
who agree what color stuff is and you're
seeing we're not lying you see it well
no
believe me one of my favorite things is
when you color normies
get into a disagreement about what color
something is that really warms my heart
like moe versus taupe
whatever it is i've seen some crazy
arguments and i like to just sit back
and listen
because usually it's just you know it's
me who's off and i know it
well can i can i just claim oppression
status here that i live in a very small
population of four here in the nuclear
family and i passed
to our two children my father's red
green colorblind gene
i of course don't i mean i carry it but
it doesn't manifest in me because
it's on the x and it gets it's it's it's
recessive
so i live in a family with three
colorblind people
uh varying degrees you've got two
different types but uh
but i'm me me the color norm you're
actually in the minority
but look i do think there's something to
the experience of like
week after week seeing a world with your
own eyes i mean it's very compelling
what you see with your eyes and then to
have the world say no you're not seeing
what you think you're seeing
does lead you a to have the sort of
confidence
of um well sometimes you do see
something that other people can't see
because
you know i i never knew whether my
dissertation work on tent making bats
was facilitated by the fact that because
i don't see color normally
the bats were less successful at
deceiving me
with their tents so after i figured out
the trick of how to find these things
i got very good at it and i could find
sometimes you know 200 in a day if i you
know
was really trying um now and these
things are these things are
super hard to find they're right i mean
it's hard when the first time you walk
into a lowland rainforested jungle a
tropical jungle
you can't see anything but a wall of
green but even once you've
spent you know years wandering around
these forests um it's much harder for me
to find these things than for you and i
know exactly what i'm looking for at
this point right yeah you've seen
hundreds of them yeah um so
anyway that's all an aside the point is
yes there is an advantage the advantage
may come
in the form of just the same way we
sometimes
colorize pictures from jupiter for
example to highlight different things
that the normal color image of the red
spot reveals different things than a
false color image
having some people who just have a
different color wheel in operation
reveals things that will be hidden um it
is certainly true
that during world war ii i believe
yeah world war ii colorblind
people were used to spot camouflage from
airplanes because they were less easily
deceived by the color of the camouflage
and that that pattern may be more
general but it may also just have this
cultural
impact where if you have the experience
of being out of sync with your
population and what it sees
it may train you to be um a little more
dogged when you think you see something
that other people don't see
you pursue it and they say no you're
getting it wrong and it's like am i
really
no and we've talked about this in a
number of places um that
um you know there may be particular
ability to detect pattern because you're
not focusing on the main thing that
people are seeing
to colorblindness but you know
left-handedness
um being on the spectrum you know all
these sorts of forms of neurodiversity
um basically you know any
any way that you are walking through
life such that you're not effectively
totally neurotypical and normie
to use to use that language um puts you
out of step enough that you may start
questioning other things that everyone
else is accepting
yeah and you know you can force this
expats sometimes
have an interesting perspective being
outside of your own culture is huge for
this i think i mean it's one it's one of
the reasons i keep on you know this is
one of my drum beats consistently like
go experience life outside of your own
especially if it's a privilege that'll
bubble
um as you know it is for most of the
activists for instance and
just be there among other people doing
their own thing
and watch how many of the things that
you thought were just sort of
fundamental to being human
are just done differently over here and
sometimes it matters and sometimes it
doesn't sometimes it's random
and sometimes most of the time it's not
and um
usually if it's persistent whatever
they're doing is better in their
environment whatever
it was happening over here was better in
this environment and uh
and it just it reveals a lot of the
biases that we actually carry around
with us
about sort of just what it is to be a
human a man
an american whatever it is
yep all right
next question i made
daniel made a new social deduction game
based on medieval era
called long live the king that you can
find at guiltfreegaming.com
long live the king it was criticized for
the lack of diversity
and he says it was based in the medieval
era should games ignore historical truth
for more inclusion
would this change help anyone
well this is this is a good question
yeah you and i have been talking about
this question
not in the context of games but in the
context of
plays theater theater yeah so we may
go and say more about this soon but i
would say
there is a
judgment call and i believe that there
is a proper place for the line
and the aspiration to be inclusive i
think
is honorable there is a level at which
the implementation can be
absolutely wrong so we've seen plays for
example where
um the you know every time you go and
see a play or
start watching a new movie or something
you have to get used to who the
characters are what their relationships
are
and um having
enough data to do it well is important
in the case that the parents of a
child in the play are of a different
race
and it causes the mind to just when it
tracks normal logic of these things
to throw an error and it causes it to be
harder to figure out who the characters
are and remember when they show up
what their relationship is that's
disruptive of the purpose of the play
and probably not a good place to do it
on the other hand and you know just
genetically nonsensical
unless in the play the kid was adopted
right right right
but that said there are lots of places
where you can do things we've seen
um the sex of a
character reversed in places yeah and
you know it can be done very badly and
it can also be done well
um we've seen races that would not have
been
uh represented in the places where the
play is taking place places and times
and we've seen it done well um we've
also seen cases in which
you know who was it
in othello i think but um anyway there's
a place where uh
the moore shows up anyway the point is
you are simultaneously trying to correct
a historical bias and trying to provide
enough
data for the mind to be able to track
what's going on but should it
so we've seen plays from a number of
theater companies
now recently in the last really 10 years
that we've been noticing this
and the ones that we keep going back to
just because of where we are
geographically but also because they're
putting on really high quality theater
are all playing around with the stuff
and um sometimes they've done it
brilliantly and sometimes they've done
it really badly
and uh we hope to see them improving
over time assuming they don't go out of
business which we hope they won't do to
covet
um but i guess part of the question here
is
you know it it has become a kind of is
becoming a kind of compelled speech
right and um really
i don't think i'll just go ahead and
answer the question that he doesn't
quite
ask here i don't think it should be
incumbent upon anyone
who is trying to create a piece of safe
fiction that takes place
in an era in which you know there
weren't a diversity of particular races
to introduce them right right for i mean
for one thing
among among many other problems doing so
requires learning about a whole bunch of
other things such that you're now
fictionalizing
people and races in a way that you're
much more likely to caricature
and actually make racial missteps yeah
right so it certainly should not be
required
i we have both seen it done well
um and it does seem to be becoming
compelled and so that would that itself
would cause me to push back against it
um but but having seen many plays that
do this
i will say that it can be done well and
it and it can
you know you know shakespeare can be
more inclusive than it
than the actual lives that he was
writing about that were
um and that is not inherently a bad
thing but um
you know the direct question should
games ignore historical truth for more
inclusion
i guess the answer is games could choose
to do that if they choose to but step
carefully and know they absolutely
should not be expected to
that said the mob is loud and growing
and we need to push back against the mob
because
um what you need is the choice to make
on your own if you're the creator
yeah i think that's the thing is that at
some level you need license to make a
decision that somebody could accuse you
of you know how dare you speak of the
medieval
medieval
europe well it existed and it was pretty
white right can you make a movie
you know about battles in world war
ii without any women in which women are
not equally represented on the
battlefield certainly you should be able
to
yes um so yes
i think the thing is anything anybody
who thinks the rule is simple
is uh misleading you yeah
if we were to develop personal
self-confidence particularly in younger
children through social emotional
learning
would it actually be a better mechanism
to the elimination of our current
divisive social issues
hello from winnipeg canada oh i
if i understand the question then
absolutely 100
absolutely yes this is this is in some
sense the whole point is
raise your children to be robust yes
anti-fragile
b to be anti-fragile don't school them
in how to
find microaggressions school them in how
to let
little stuff you know just disappear
without worrying about it because for
one thing
you're just never going to know in most
cases whether the microaggression is
really a microaggression or whether
you're reading something into it
that isn't there and so all of us
have to be this way we all get little
things that feel like slights that
weren't really and sometimes they
are and if you dwell on that stuff
you'll just your brain will overheat
now and this you know personal
self-confidence absolutely so expose
your children early and often
to the physical world and you know
expose them to risks that grow over time
you don't want them getting hurt you
really don't want them getting killed
but allowing them to get hurt sometimes
such that they have learned
from what they did and are less likely
to make those kinds of decisions going
forward
means that they are far less likely to
grow up and become the kind of you know
cartoon character
like wiley coyote who uh you know
so doesn't believe in gravity it doesn't
actually fall until he looks down
right you know this is the the world
view that imagines that wiley coyote is
scooting off a cliff and not falling
until he knows that he should fall
is the kind of mischaracterization of
physics that we are we are raising in
kids and
you know to to those who would say what
are you talking about physics isn't
socio-emotional learning well it is like
that's
that's how you get it because expose
kids
in groups and alone to the physical
universe and then allow
them to start seeding those ideas and
those things that they've learned into
their friend groups
and among their siblings and they will
figure out uh
very quickly what's true in the universe
and what's not what's right and what's
not what's just what's kind what's
generous and what's not
so many of these things there is some
line to be drawn somewhere
like with bullying right bullying sucks
but the bully in your child's school
yard is actually part of the education
right you have to know how to deal with
bullies if you're going to melt in the
face of bullies or figure out who you
can go run to
you are not very well positioned for the
adult world
so there's all sorts of stuff that has
to do with you know the way
friends like probe each other for
vulnerabilities and exploit them and
call each other out
that stuff may not be pretty as you're
looking at it but it is part of figuring
out how to deal with a complex world
that isn't built to be safe and the
world is just not a safe space you can't
make it one
so you know is there is there some level
of bullying that you
want to punish at the level of the
adults yeah but
is it anything you know any hint that
somebody is being mean
no it's not and we've got to stop
telling ourselves that
you know we know what's good and bad you
know are arguments bad
no arguments aren't bad arguments are a
way to figure out what you actually
think
if you decide that arguments are bad and
they're therefore not allowed and
anybody who engages in them
is a bad person you're uh you're
destroying people's ability to to reason
yeah okay uh how how far in are we
sac
oh boy okay we're gonna do two more here
and then we'll skip to the other stream
okay isn't cancel culture just online
simon says the leader yells commands and
you must comply as quickly as possible
but they're trying to trick you into
making a mistake
one wrong move and you're removed from
the game yeah
there's a lot to be said for them that's
right yep
i recently saw boyce's evergreen doc
also read the denial of death which is
not a book i'm familiar with
what's up with the fetishistic use of
bodies to describe people of color
uh thoughts on tmt evolutionarily i
don't know what tmt is
i'm not tmt is the left egging on a most
a massive
reaction to mortality salience oh that's
interesting but yeah we've talked
a bit in the past about this this use of
bodies and you know i find it
explicitly dehumanizing i think it it
removes
the whole the whole being into its
constituent parts
pretends that we aren't emergent hue
whole humans
and focuses on the physical well okay
i'm going to defend it okay
i don't think it's useful in the way we
see it and i find it jarring exactly as
you do
you know when people are described as if
that's what they were yeah they
are bodies that's a misuse but i think
originally it comes from ton of hazy
coats
and that his point which i agree with
is that ultimately oppression comes down
to
the control of somebody's body right
that there's a lot of stuff that happens
in the space of what is said and what is
believed but ultimately
this is about things in the physical
universe it's about the body's access to
resources the body's ability to be free
and that may not be perfectly
accurate but i find it insightful and
important
what's troubling is just with you know
critical race theory
there's some kernel at the bottom of it
that's important that then gets
drawn into this ideology that makes
that turns it into nonsense and what's
more pernicious nonsense
so the idea of describing people as if
they were simply bodies
is obviously absurd and it is
dehumanizing exactly as you say
but the idea of tracking the way
in which somebody's body is being
controlled by some
unethical force is important and so i
would you know
there are a lot of these things i would
like to rescue the important thing from
the bad thing
you know woke used to be an honorable
meaningful term it's now a garbage term
but it'd be lovely to be able to recover
the original thing because it actually
mattered
yeah very good first question
from this super chat q a super chat
is anyone tracking what medications were
administered
sorry is anyone tracking what
medications were administered to people
who have lingering symptoms
that is such a good question and i don't
know i've not seen anything on this
topic
well i can tell you we do a terrible job
of this about
everything right so there we are running
an experiment we are the lab rats
in some giant experiment where we are
having drugs administered to us that
nobody could possibly know what their
long-term effects
are and the problem is if you just think
through the logic
of let's say um
i mean in this case we know that
that erythromycin does heart damage but
that was
very late emerging that piece of
information your doctor probably still
doesn't know it
yeah the point is you had lots of people
being
administered erythromycin it works it's
a very functional antibiotic
what would have to happen you go on it
you get rid of your infection
and you go off it how much damage does
it have to do
before somebody puts together the
pattern oh that person was on
erythromycin 25 years ago and now they
have
you know a heart problem yeah right
there's no way unless you're tracking
what should be happening and this is
increasingly beginning to happen in some
places
is you have to track everything that
some population takes so that you can
then go back and look at the data and
say all right
did the people who took erythromycin in
their 20s have any reduced
longevity right so i mean that's that's
huge obviously and we should be doing we
we should be doing this and it's very
difficult to do yeah in this
one way at least the coveted problem is
more sa is more solvable like it's more
tractable because the time
the time period is so much shorter right
so yeah i mean it does what
one thing you didn't say that adds
complexity of course is that all the
supplements and over-the-counter things
that people are taking that may be
interacting badly with diseases or other
medications um we aren't tracking
because
we just don't even we just don't even we
pretend we don't even care and it
doesn't matter
but this is you know if we go back to
one of the discussions we had at the
very
beginning of our series of live streams
here we argued
that military bases for example
constitute
populations that you could track over
time and maybe
you should get hazard pay
or something you should get paid for
keeping track of all of the things
including the supplements that you
used on your own yeah you should
definitely you need to get something for
giving up
this level of privacy for some period of
time right like you know we're asking
for
for for some authority some research
authority which presumably has some
government
presence in it to be able to look into
your medicine cabinet and everything
that you're putting in your mouth that's
that's a very big breach of privacy
but um you know many people would be
willing to do that for a period of time
uh and you know especially if it came
with right and kind of
it could be anonymized you know we could
we could address the privacy concerns so
that you know
there was some method of authentication
in which the data went in and according
to some number that
nobody could track yeah um but what we
need to do is we need to re we need to
denoise the data
so that it's not up to physicians to
detect some pattern months or years down
the road
to ask exactly the right question of of
the patient and have the patient know
exactly what to say at the right time
right and the answer is so much
eetrogenic
harm that is to say medically caused
harm is the result
of the fact that our data is too noisy
for us to be able to track
even really important patterns like yeah
that drug you took
uh you know caused your achilles tendon
to be
fragile and to break or knocked ten
years off your life
or any of these things you can't notice
that in a clinical
setting you have to get it from a large
enough sample in which you've collected
really good data on what people took
and you have no idea how much time
you're doing to yourself
yeah next question
in order to learn the lesson about
authoritarianism would it be would it
help to illegalize intellectual bullying
of the kind that is happening now
it's interesting that question came in
before we talked about bullying right
uh it's it's this one i'll read it again
in order to learn the lesson about
authoritarianism would it help to
illegalize intellectual bullying of the
kind that is happening now
i think illegalizing bullying
has the problem that we see across
platforms
with regard to you know what point at
what point are you
stepping in uh appropriately and at what
point is it inappropriate when is it
censorship when is it not when is it
bullying when is it not
uh so you know like like you said to
speaking to bullying just a few minutes
ago like i said before this question
came in
um or rather no this question was asked
before you spoke to it
um bullying is real
there's a real hazard to it but the way
that our school yards have responded to
it
um is ridiculous and um antithetical
actually to
creating robust and anti-fragile
children
yeah i would i would suspect that the
same would be true over an intellectual
bullying space
i would agree completely yeah and i
think illegalizing it is going to
backfire yeah two-part question
one what does reaching out to potential
dark horse candidates look like
two are grad students in a unique
position to handle this great awokening
i am a graduate physics student go
stem so first question what is reaching
out to potential directors candidates
look like
well there's a reason we phrased this as
a draft and i think the basic
problem is that we have a national
emergency
and we are seeking candidates who are
patriotic courageous and capable and we
believe that in the end such
people are very likely to recognize that
that we need them and that as much as
they don't want to do the job and i
think a great many people
who might be identified by this process
will not want the job the smart ones
they won't want it but
um but that's to say um that's the whole
reason for phrasing it as a draft so
what does it look like
we will find that out when we have our
candidates some of them will be easier
to reach and some of them will be more
difficult to reach
but a patriotic appeal to
the nation and the world's well-being
and the catastrophe of having
two people who are both disinclined
towards leadership and growing too old
to to affect it
calls upon the rest of us to do things
we might not otherwise do
and the second part of the question
which is different
asks if graduate students are in a
unique position to handle this great
awokening
asked by a graduate student in physics
i think they're in a terrible position
yeah and so
in some ways it's it's just as hard a
position as there is because you're
still a student
you're still trapped in the university
system and you're completely
at the at the whim of the administration
the department the faculty
if you're teaching of the undergraduates
as well you can just you can get it
every which way
yep i'm afraid on the other hand i i
would love to know what
what you see is the potential um to
the potential upside to being in that
position maybe
um because being a graduate student
sucks and
the job that you're supposed to get at
the end of it doesn't exist you have
less to lose and
can therefore afford to be bolder yeah
maybe although i mean most
yes one thing that's true uh that may
not be
well known outside of being a graduate
student in stem
at least this is always what what the
advice i always gave to
to my students when they were thinking
about graduate school one of the things
was
um do not go into graduate school do not
do not
accept any position for which you will
end up in more debt at the end of it
that basically graduate school in stem
should pay for itself you will end up
with rich you will end up you know
not with very much money at all to live
on but basically because the stem fields
are such high demand
with regard to graduate students you're
basically very low paid labor
to do either research or teaching you
should never have
any any new debt that comes in whereas
graduate school across the board
is money making opportunity over in
humanities and social sciences and
arts for the university i reckon it's a
racket it's a total recommence a bracket
in a different way yeah for stem
students but
master students in stem is a little bit
different but basically if you
if you are accruing debt as a graduate
student in stem
you should probably find a different
program um so
that said what you are doing is if you
don't end up with a degree you were sort
of treading water with nothing to put on
your resume or your cv at the end of it
but at the very least you shouldn't end
up in in a worse financial position than
you were when you started
you know whatever undergraduate debt you
came in with you still have but you
don't have any new debt
yep
in early mammals clitorises tend to
tend to be part of the vagina and
trigger ovulation
in humans what is the advantage if it's
evolving to be outside
if the main benefit is to have less
ovulations why hasn't it disappeared
i think that i'm not sure that the
second part of this
um the last part of that i'm not sure
how it follows if the main benefit is to
have less ovulations
um why can can you track why that would
be
the guess as to why it has evolved to be
on the outside
i'm not following it and i'm um
i'm puzzling over the beginning part of
the question because my guess
based on too little information but
some is that clitorises and early
mammals are not playing the
role that they're playing where they're
important which is in a very small
number of taxa
so it's not it's not i don't i don't
know that they're not but i i'm pretty
sure we don't
know well in any case i
you know this is the second time we've
been asked about the external placement
which has an interpretation but i wonder
actually so this is from echo
um you you know very smart very
knowledgeable
um and and i'm in touch with you
um over email um if you have
access to a paper or eight or something
um send them to me so that we can make
more
sense of this and and uh yes this is
becoming an increasingly dominant topic
in our at least q a
section we ought to at least get it
right yeah that's right
um what are the roots of circumcision of
infant males in the west what are the
evolutionary advantages if any of
foreskin so okay
this is where we finally get cancelled
i know this discussion and it is a
catastrophe
yep here's the key piece of information
that you need
i have deployed years ago now on my
channel something that i used to teach
from which was the
adaptive test a test to tell whether
something should be assumed to be the
product of adaptive
evolution and it consists of a diagnosis
of whether something
a characteristic a behavior or a
structure is complex
whether it has a cost whether that cost
can be reduced
and yet it persists over evolutionary
time the logic being
if you have such a structure like the
appendix the appendix is a complex
structure
that really is independently enough to
suggest
the role of adaptation in its creation
but to be conservative
it is a structure that can be reduced so
that is to say that the expense that
goes into
the appendix can be reduced over time
and yet it persists which implies that
it is paying the cost
of it and as we discussed last time in
the case of the appendix that would also
be the risk
of having it and therefore the
adaptation is of a magnitude that we can
approximate even if we don't know
what the advantage is now the reason i
go through that
is that in the case of the foreskin and
circumcision
they both pass the adaptive test which
is to say
the foreskin was built by adaptation it
has
a value that more than covers the cost
of its production
the removal of it also has an adaptive
meaning
the removal of it is something that has
persisted
over evolutionary time in spite of the
cost and the risk
of it so what that tells us is that
there's a tension here
between values and it may be
that in some places the
value of the foreskin outweighs the risk
of removal
it may be that in other places the
reverse is true it may be that in some
cultural contexts the value of it
uh exceeds the cost of removal or vice
versa
and so that is the kind of answer we are
looking for anybody whose answer comes
down to
this is uh this is
mutilation and should be halted because
it has no
value has misunderstood misunderstood
the implication of circumcision
being a long-standing practice whether
you know it could be that the
circumcision is a bit like the appendix
in the sense that the thing that made it
valuable
is no longer present in our environment
and therefore at this point
the value is not there there's obviously
lots of debate over the implications
for disease so there was a very
popular piece of research that suggested
that it was preventative
of things like aids
it may be that hygiene compensates for
that advantage it may be that that
um that data did not indicate what
people thought it did that the
methodology was no good
so it is a very complex environment but
the thing you want look if you're gonna
walk away from the dark horse podcast
with something to say on this topic
that will make you more enlightened
than other people it is that both the
foreskin and its removal
are adaptive right that doesn't tell you
which context you should expect
preservation versus removal but it does
tell you you're looking for something at
least complicated enough to deal with
that
set of truths
beautiful uh we're probably at about an
hour zach
okay um there are a couple of big uh
money questions here
so we are going to try to get through
four more here and i've saved one that
we are going to save
uh for the top of next time so let's go
through four more questions
uh today could joe rogan
and or dave chappelle be the wealthy and
patriotic citizens that eric called for
during the campfire
you've got joe's phone number right um
well so first of all i have to be
there's a squirrel in distress outside
um
her cats are all inside so okay i think
it can fend for itself dealing with its
own distress
um here's the thing first of all joe is
a friend
i don't want to put joe in any position
uh that
isn't warranted so the question is
i don't think this is a monetary issue i
think the thing is joe
is in a unique position in society at
the moment
he is somebody who has proven the
ability to acquire a gigantic audience
to cover
a range of different topics including
very controversial stuff
to live to tell the tale so far at least
and
the question is you know does one want
to call up joe
and have him put himself in some kind of
jeopardy over something that's really a
question
for joe to answer whether this is that
something because certainly the risk
of not having joe playing the role that
he is playing and
his ability to assess what his risks are
is much greater than our ability to
assess them
that's not it's not something anybody
else can answer so
i think eric's uh invitation to whoever
it might be
is really a question for somebody to
figure out
whether they are in a position to be
able to play that role and whether they
uh the desire to play that role
has a cost that isn't worth paying
somewhere else can't answer it for
anybody
yeah okay the next question is about
consciousness and big brains
in homo sapiens and i think we're gonna
save this for next time but also we can
point to
um our princeton talk which
uh which spoke to the evolution of
consciousness
in in humans but we will we will address
this at the top i would just say
i like big brains i cannot lie no
in peru in peru it has been ruled that
subjective gender identity is going to
be what determines what is written in
your national id
this obliterates any relationship with
objective reality
why not have different categories for
different levels of sex and gender
yeah that's really unfortunate i have no
knowledge of this i'm assuming that the
person writing the question does um but
it does
you know yes why every time we are
every time that we are asked what's your
sex
and they give us 87 options or something
if they're going to spend the time to do
that then they should have given us two
different questions
what's your sex and what's your gender
identity
and for those people who think it's
important to care about gender identity
and there are contexts in which it is
quite important for many people that
will still give them the opportunity to
describe what they view as as their
gender identity
but their actual sex which has
ramifications
across the board including for their own
health
uh would not be diminished or made
invisible by
uh whatever particular possible fantasy
space they're living in at the moment
so i would just link this up with
something we've said about
utopians in general that utopians tend
to be people
who a are too convinced that they know
how to blueprint the solution to some
problem and that b
tend to be focused on solving one
problem and completely unaware of what
the unintended consequences of what they
do
will be and i would just say that this
is sexual utopianism
where there's one thing that is being
targeted here and it's
the comfort of people who are
having some different gender experience
than
normal right and the idea is we cannot
have
anybody even thinking that there's
anything
true and absolute about sex because that
will
potentially cause a person who is let's
say trans
to have to grapple with the
discontinuity between
their subjective experience and the
objective assertions of people who are
involved in
giving you a driver's license or
whatever and the point is look
you can solve your one problem and you
will cause who knows
how many other arbitrary dangerous
difficult problems elsewhere
or you can grow the [ __ ] up right i mean
seriously you can grow up and you can
recognize
that yes the comfort of trans people
over their gender situation
is a factor it's an important factor
period the end right you cannot crash
civilization over somebody's comfort
over something anybody's mind yours
anything this isn't about your comfort
this is about a
functioning system and some of them seem
really not able
to grow up right like for to for some of
them
their developmental environment the
drugs they were given their families
their screens
some combination therein have actually
kept them from having the ability to
grow the [ __ ] up
yeah and the thing is that's not a
failure of compassion
that is to say you know you know we
can't turn off the engines of the
airplane because
the sound is driving you crazy right
but it's annoying it's annoying granted
it may even literally be driving you
crazy but the engines have to remain
on you know until we get to the ground
and then we can talk about whether you
could take the train but
you know please please do if if that's
going to be your complaint please take
the train which also isn't going to be
quiet
it's not going to be that quiet but you
know not in the u.s you can't crash
civilization
over issues of comfort no matter how
real they may be yeah
okay uh two last questions um
just that came in at high high money
value so um
i don't think we can actually answer
this one but i wanted to read it
have you read the revolutionary
phenotype before i finish the question i
will say i have not i don't even know it
i have not it's ringing a bell it's on
my list somewhere after it was released
the field of origin of life and early
evolution went silent they can't
debunk it because it is true but also
can't acknowledge it because the writer
is an outsider
so i don't i don't know this book is it
an evolution space is that the idea
i guess so yeah so i uh like i say i
don't know it i'm gonna
try to make time to look at it um enough
to know if it's easy to say yeah
actually this is where it's wrong or
actually this is one of these things
that um that deserves
deserves discussion and perhaps the
person writing the question is right
it's not discussed because the writer
isn't already in the fold
but i don't neither of us know at this
point so final question for today
neurological or conscious mutation
sorry i'm just it's not they're not
quite enough words here i'm trying to
see how to read it
consciousness mutation i'll just i'll
just
read it i'm not sure it quite makes
sense neurological or consciousness
mutation for what we are seeing and the
reason they do not make sense to anyone
outside their circle
are these few evolving to be hyper
tolerant outsider intolerant to the
point of superiority or destruction
i think
um let's i'm let's maybe try to come
back to that one see if we can make
sense of it
next time because i i wanted to get to
it yeah
but i just i the words it's too dense
and there aren't quite enough connecting
words
so because i said i would do one more
i'm gonna we're gonna go to this one
hey bretton heather are you familiar
with ian mcgilchrist the master in his
emissary
would love to hear your thoughts on the
evolutionary reasons for having two
brain hemispheres
do you agree with mcgillcrist thank you
so this this
i didn't read all of it it's very long
it's a very long book
but he's great and it's it's a very
interesting and important book we were
on stage with him
yeah 14 months ago or so in may of 2019
along with our friend jordan hall at the
rebel wisdom summit
in london um
we don't agree with him on everything
but i am trying to remember exactly what
his position
on the brain hemispheres are i did i did
speak to him a little bit one-on-one
backstage about brain hemispheres
because so um
lateralization which is having um not
we are bilaterally symmetrical and we
have been since we were early
vertebrates
um never never have gone into radial
symmetry since then
or so um but having two halves that are
roughly mirror images of one another
across the left right axis
um does not mean that those two halves
inherently do different things
and so at the point that we start
talking about brain lateralization is
the point at which we can see that
actually the two brain halves the left
and the right are doing different things
and then stemming from that sort of
downstream effects of that including
include things like having handedness
and footedness and earedness and
eyedness
and so lateralization where you actually
have different stuff happening
in the left half of your brain and your
right half of the brain
begins to um show up pretty early in
vertebrate history but really
really becomes manifest in both
birds and mammals separately that's
convergent evolution
in in two of them because it's different
brain parts actually that become the
large brains in birds and mammals
uh and let's see just one more thing
about the history here that i wanted to
get to
and i've now forgotten what it was
um with regard to
maybe you want to riff a little bit okay
one other thing i want to say about
lateralization but i can't remember
it'll come back to you yeah uh so i
would say
i'm a bit familiar with the gilchrist
model
there's a great rsa animate that he uh
narrated which covers it pretty
succinctly in a short period of time
and it's been a while since i've seen it
so i've now forgotten what his
um his two components were doing
i'm seeing the animation in my mind but
i don't have it exactly
but i thought it was very high quality
and that it dealt with a lot of the
issues of the standard right
left brain dichotomy garbage that
doesn't add up most of it's garbage yeah
right and so anyway as far as i'm aware
mcgill chris and i at least have only
one important disagreement we might have
a different
sense of certain things but i've found
him very compelling on this topic
the place where we part company is
pansysm where he
does seem to believe that there's some
consciousness written into the
matter of the universe and i find this
preposterous
i will say though it was the marvelous
case we disagreed with this in pers
about this in person
it had no implication for our sense that
we were talking to a kindred spirit it
was very
uh very rewarding interaction and i
think it's a
great demonstration that you can degree
or disagree over something absolutely
fundamental
and then you know where that
disagreement no longer has any
implications
and everything else um is just simply
enlightening and productive
and you know it was exactly that
experience yeah now he is he is
fabulous he's he's really uh an amazing
human being
kindred spirit like you said um so i was
trying to sort of riff and bide time to
see if i could prompt myself to remember
exactly what his position
on lateralization in the brain is and i
just don't remember it so i will speak
to
what you know what i have said before um
and
what i have thought before with regard
to um you know why why two brain
well two brain hemispheres is is
something we have inherited from
our mammalian ancestors from way back
even before there appears to be distinct
functioning between them
as soon as you have two distinct brain
hemispheres the cerebral cortex you also
have the evolution of what in mammals is
called the corpus callosum
which is a neurological band of fibers
that connects the two
so this raises the question of course if
you are going to separate
your two main parts of your braid that
are doing sort of thinking into the
future and thinking in the back you know
scenario building and memory
uh and you know and planning and
reflection and all of these things that
are cerebral cortex is so excellent at
um why if you're going to separate it
are you then going to bring them back
together
well there's real benefit in being able
to
hide some things from yourself over here
or to specialize and localize a task
over here while
the other part of your brain is doing
something else over here and
in fact we we see predictable
differences in the size of the corpus
callosum that connects the two
hemispheres
based on some demographic markers and
we've raised this before and i'm
actually i have not gone back and looked
to see that this has
stood the test of time but what i used
to say to my students when this would
come up in class
which again i'm not positive is totally
up to date
was that on average women and
left-handers
and homosexuals have larger corpus
callosums than do men or right-handers
or heterosexual people
and um if you just think in terms of ah
this thing that we've got is good
therefore i want a bigger one
you will feel a little bit out of the
loop if you're a right-handed straight
male but of course it's not like that
like you for instance for example for
example whereas i get two of them right
like i'm i'm a left-handed woman so okay
my corpus callosum
on average is likely to be you can't
tell until i'm dead so don't try to
check
um um we could scan yes you could
probably scan but yeah
um on average larger than someone who
didn't have either of those demographic
markers but
so what like what is it better for so
what does a more integrated left and
right brain
bring you perhaps a greater um maybe
greater executive function which is this
i i don't love the term executive
function
but um i think that there is separate
psychological neurological evidence that
women on average have better
executive function than men it has to do
with sort of organizing
things and spaces and keeping track of
calendars and things like this
right and that that might well be
a result of a more integrated brain in
which it is also harder to hide things
from yourself
so the flip side of that why would you
maybe want a brain that has
less frequent or able connection between
the two hemispheres maybe you can
partition and specialize and go deep and
block out the rest of the world to the
enduring irritation of those around you
was that personal and and you know and
and really dive deep more effectively
um than if you had a bigger copper's
closer you know that's
that's hypothesis i don't know that
that's true but can you imagine
a trade-off between having a more
integrated versus more separate
separate brain of course you can and is
one better
no one's better in some circumstances
for some tasks and the other is better
in some other circumstances for some
kinds of tasks
so in closing i would just say we've got
a number of different models one
the the typical one uh that we hear left
right brain
you know analytical artistic yeah that's
nonsense
um the mastering this emissary version
is really cool
there's a another like a bicameral brain
model that i think has a lot of merit to
it i've deployed one which i will
explore more fully
uh at some place that has to do with um
an interaction between consciousness and
unconsciousness
uh but anyway there is there is a theme
to be explored
and the early simple diagnoses turn out
to be wrong
there is a trade-off based on
connectivity versus
uh separability there that's evident in
the structural differences
and anyway it's a very it's a very
important um
topic but somewhere in that neighborhood
yep
all right here we are and we number 37
number 37
done and done it's in the cam
not yet zach still has some work to do
yeah well that's true yeah
so unity 2020 unity 2020 go to
unity uh no articles of unity.org
nominate you can nominate two people and
we will
move quickly to a process of discussion
of the merits of the various candidates
and then on to a vote about who it is we
want to draft
we hope to have candidates by the
beginning of september
you can join the discord server at
either of our patreons or
become darkhorse member at my patreon
and join a private q a once a month
and uh be great if you subscribe to the
channel like the video
all of that we are working on upcoming
unity campfires
they will be uh do we know yet when the
next one will be we are hoping for
wednesday but i have to nail down a
guest so
i can't promise it yet uh all right
um until next time be well